ever wondered how google translates an
entire webpage to a different language
in a matter of seconds or your phone
gallery groups images based on their
location all of this is a product of
deep learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior machine learning is a technique
to achieve AI through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the Machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine now
let's dive into the working of neural
networks here we have three students
each of them write down the digit nine
on a piece of paper notably they don't
all write it identically the human brain
can easily recognize the digits but what
if a computer had to recognize them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits each number
is present as an image of 28 times 28
pixels now that amounts to a total of
784 pixels neurons the core entity of a
neural network is where the information
processing takes place each of the 784
pixels is fed to a neuron in the first
layer of our neural network this forms
the input layer on the other end we have
the output layer with each neuron
representing a digit with the hidden
layers existing between them the
information is trans
from one layer to another over
connecting channels each of these has a
value attached to it and hence is called
a weighted Channel all neurons have a
unique number associated with it called
bias this bias is added to the weighted
sum of inputs reaching the neuron which
is then applied to a function known as
the activation function the result of
the activation function determines if
the neuron gets activated every
activated neuron passes on information
to the following layers this continues
up till the second last layer the one
neuron activated in the output layer
corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support
when most people converse with customer
support agents the conversation seems so
real they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze MRI images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality Apple Tesla and Nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
Train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training and neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of course as
compared to CPUs and GPUs are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here
a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added be the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated see specific
neuron is activated D the result is fed
to an activation function leave your
answers in the comments section below
three of you stand a chance to win
Amazon vouchers so hurry some of the
popular deep learning frameworks include
tensorflow
high torch caris deep learning Forge a
cafe and Microsoft cognitive toolkit
considering the future predictions for
deep learning and AI we seem to have
only scratched the surface in fact horse
technology is working on a device for
the blind that uses deep learning with
computer vision to describe the world to
the users replicating the human mind at
the entirety may be not just an episode
of science fiction or too long the
future is indeed full of surprises and
that is deep learning for you in short
if you enjoyed this video do like and
share it also subscribe to our channel
if you haven't yet as we have a lot more
exciting videos coming up fun learning
till then